i'm now going to show you what i think
are are probably the two coolest
derivatives
in all of calculus and i'll reserve that
um i haven't
none of the other ones have occurred to
me right now but these are definitely to
me some of the neatest so let's figure
out what the derivative of the natural
log is and just as a review what is the
natural log well
the natural log of something is the same
thing
it's the exact same thing as saying
logarithm
base e of that something
that's just a review so let's take the
derivative of this
so the derivative
actually let me i think i'm going to
need a lot of space for this and try to
do it as neatly as possible so the
derivative
of the natural log
of x
equals well let's just take the
definition of of a derivative right we
just take the slope at some point and
find the limit at as as we take the
difference between the two points to
zero
so let's take the limit
as
delta x
delta x approaches 0
of
f of
x plus delta x so in this case it would
be something the limit of this whole
thing
the natural log
ln
of x plus delta x right that's like one
point that i'm going to take
evaluate the function minus the ln
of x
all of that over delta x and if you
remember from the derivative videos this
is just the slope and i'm just taking
the limit as i find the slope between a
smaller and a smaller distance
hopefully you remember that
so let's see if we can use some
logarithm properties to simplify this a
little bit
hopefully you remember and if you don't
review the logarithm properties but
remember that log
of a
minus log
of b
is equal to
log
of a over b and that comes out of the
fact that these are that logarithm
expressions are essentially exponents so
they follow the exponent rules
and if that doesn't make sense to you
you should review those as well but
let's apply this
logarithm property to this equation so
let me write rewrite the whole thing and
i'm going to keep switching colors to
keep it from getting
monotonous we have the limit
as delta x approaches 0
of this big thing
let's see so
log of a minus b is equal to log a over
b so
this top the numerator will equal the
natural log the natural log of x
plus delta x
over
x
right a b
a over b
all of that
over delta x
and so that equals
the limit
as delta x approaches zero i think it's
time to switch colors again
delta x approaches 0
of
well let me just write this 1 over delta
x out in front
so this is 1 over
delta x remember take the limit of
everything
ln
of x divided by x is 1
plus
delta
x
over
fair enough
now i'm going to throw out another
logarithm property and hopefully you
remember that
and let me let me put the properties
separate so you know it's not part of
the proof
that a
log
b
is equal to
log
of b to the a that comes from when you
multiply when you take something to an
exponent and then to another exponent
you just have to multiply those two
exponents i don't want to confuse you
but hopefully you should remember this
so what where is this how does this
apply here well this would be a log b so
this expression is the same thing as
i will switch colors again
the limit
the limit as delta
x
approaches zero
of
the natural log
one plus
delta x
over x
to the
1 over
delta x power and remember all of this
is within the it's the natural log of
this entire thing and then we're going
to take the limit as delta x approaches
0. if you remember if you've watched the
compound interest problems and you know
the definition of e i think this will
start to look familiar but let me make a
substitution that might clean things up
a little bit
let me make the substitution
oh i don't know let me call it
let me call it
n
no no let me call
u
is equal to delta x
over x
and then if that's true then we can
multiply both sides by x and we get x u
is equal to delta x
or
we would also know that 1 over delta x
is equal to
1 over
x u right all of that these are all
equivalent so let's make the
substitution so if we're taking the
limit as delta x approaches zero
in this expression if delta x approaches
zero what does u approach you approach
zero so delta x approaching zero is the
same exact thing as taking the limit as
u approaches zero
right so we can write this as the limit
as u
approaches zero
of the natural log
of
one plus we did the substitution delta x
over x is now u
to the
one over delta x and that same
substitution told us that's the same
thing as one over x u
one over x
u
remember taking the natural log of
everything
and we know this this is an exponent
property which i'll now do in a
different color
we know that
a to the b
c
is equal to a to the b
to the c power right
so that tells us that this let me
separate all of this off
is equal to the limit i'm trying to save
space
the limit
of as u
approaches 0 of the natural log
of
1 plus u
to the 1 over u because this is this is
1 over x u right
1 over u
and then all of that
to the 1 over x and how did i do that
just from this exponent property right
if i were to simplify this i would have
1 over x times 1 over u and that's where
i get this 1 over
x u
well then we can just do this logarithm
property in reverse right if i have b to
the a i can put that a out front so i
could take this 1 over x and put it in
front of the natural log
so now what do i have we're almost there
we have the limit
as u approaches zero
take that one over x put in front of the
natural log sign
1 over x
times
the natural log
of 1 plus u
to the 1 over
u
fair enough we're taking the limit as u
approaches zero x
this term doesn't involve it at all it
doesn't uh so we could take this out in
front because the limit doesn't affect
this term and we're essentially saying
what happens to
this expression
as the limit as u approaches zero right
so this thing is equivalent to
one over x
times the natural log
times the natural log of
the limit
as u approaches zero
of
one plus
u
to the one over u
and by now hopefully you would recognize
that this is this is the definition this
this limit
comes to e if you remember anything from
compound interest you might you might
remember it as the limit
as n approaches infinity of 1 plus 1
over n
to the n but these things are equivalent
if you just took the substitution u is
equal to 1 over n you would get this
you would just get this so this
expression right here
this expression is e that expression is
e so we're getting close so all of this
is equivalent to
so this whole thing
1 over x
times the natural log and this we know
this is one of the ways to get to e
so the limit is u plus 0 of 1 plus u to
the 1 over u that is e
and what is the natural log what's the
log base e so you know this is equal to
1 over x
times the log
base e of e so that's saying e to what
power is e well e to the first power is
e right this is equal to one
so one times one over x is equal to one
over x
there we have it the derivative of the
natural log of x
is equal to 1 over x which i find kind
of neat because all of the other
exponents
lead to another exponent but all of a
sudden in the mix here you have the
natural log and the derivative of that
is equal to x to the negative 1 or 1
over x
fascinating